hi I'm Eric Voss and Toy Story Ford
proved that Pixar can make us cry over
toys without shoving them into a furnace
Woody's adventure with porky Bo Peep is
filled with hidden Easter eggs that
reference pretty much every other Pixar
movie including ones that haven't come
out yet so let us rewatch this movie's
scene-by-scene for the deeper meaning
and details that you might have
overlooked spoiler warning if you
haven't seen Toy Story 4 yet and let's
get started ok the opening scene it's a
flashback said 9 years previously
showing the story of how Bo Peep parted
ways with them a departure hinted at in
Toy Story 3 yeah we've lost friends
along the way
Bo Peep yeah even even though all good
toys who've gone on to new owners
thankfully that wasn't just a cover
story for Bo actually getting Furness
during this rain ERC rescue Andy's mom
gives away the Bo Peep lamp and the
recipients license plate reads an RM RF
97 which is the deep cut Pixar Easter
Egg it's the infamous command code
entered by an unknown Pixar employee
during the production of Toy Story 2
that accidentally started deleting all
the movies assets from the server until
the servers were unplugged just the
right moment and a remote backup
miraculously saved the film from being
completely deleted also during this
flashback a calendar on Andy's wall
features the characters from a bug's
life jumping ahead to the present day
the toys are now with Bonnie the girl
that Andy left them with at the end of
Toy Story 3 and she now favors Jessie
leaving woody to gather dust bunnies in
the closet Woody's journey in this story
is a metaphor for retirement after a
lifetime of always being there for a
child how does one redefine their
purpose without becoming obsolete Toy
Story 3 is excellent as it was never
address the question of what happens to
lost toys not all neglected toys have to
become lot so do they surely they can be
forgotten by kids without turning evil
so this film proposes that being
forgotten can also mean being free
gotten Bonnie is struggling with
kindergarten orientation and in her
classroom are a few more Pixar Easter
eggs if you're looking closely but
before I continue thank you to read
shadow legends for sponsoring this
episode
read is the brand new free-to-play
mobile RPG with the most amazing
storyline awesome 3d graphics giant boss
fights in more than
400 champions to collect and customize
this game will remind you of the classic
RPG and strategy games and and get under
devices and now your phone you'll enjoy
the crazy battles and events that'll get
you hooked immediately and it's all you
old-school gamers out there who like me
don't play as mini games anymore trust
me it will come back to you we just look
at the crazy level of detail on these
champions this lady's got like flies
swirling around her then he got this
fellow who's like currently on fire and
then Hey look at this wee lad
I love how his weapon is a mug of beer
yeah raids graphics the storyline are
comparable to triple-a console games but
this game is free-to-play and it has a
nearly perfect score in the Play Store I
mean with a score like that this games
got to be onto something right lead is
growing super fast and look out for a
huge update this month that'll be pure
fun for new players it's really the best
time to join the action folks so what
are you waiting for go down to the
description click on these special links
to download raid and you will instantly
get 50,000 silver and a free epic
champion as part of the new player
program to start your journey good luck
and I'll see you there okay back to the
Easter eggs in Bonnie's classroom
there's a lunch box with the battlesaurs
from Toy Story that time for God
Christmas special short also one of her
classmates I'm pretty sure because it
looks a lot like her is boo from
Monsters Inc boo also appears to make a
cameo later as one of the kids at the
carnival booth Bonnie comforts herself
by making 4 key voiced by Tony Hale out
of a spork in arts and crafts odds and
ends at woody pulls from the trash for
Bonnie movies first act 4 key struggles
in an existential crisis he sees himself
as trash he tries to toss himself out
over and over again but woody tells him
you are a toy a nod to Woody's famous
words to buzz in the first film
Bonnie's parents take her on an
end-of-summer road trip at one point to
stop at a Dinoco gas station the brand
that Woody and Buzz got straight of that
in the first film also during this trip
they get fried chicken from poultry
palace which is a location from the Toy
Story shorts small fry and a place city
you can actually eat at in Disneyland if
you'll need to review poultry palace
food in the video tweet please send Eric
to Disneyland at new rock stars aunt at
Phil Molina thank you
then they arrived at a small town with a
carnival which is littered with even
more Pixar Easter eggs do you look
closely there is a balloon
the same kind that Carl worked at and up
one of the attractions is called dragon
zone and on its banner is a little
dragon now this is actually Blasi the
pet dragon from the upcoming Pixar
feature at Pixar almost always hides an
easter egg for the next film somewhere
in the background of the current film
like an Incredibles to do kaboom was
actually visible in Jack Jack's crib
also in this carnival there's a ship it
truck which we saw in the Toy Story
short Toy Story of terror and there's
another sign with a clown painted on the
side which looks a lot like the clown
from Pixar's 1987 Short Reds dream and
then there's this large purple ride that
many said resembles the toys stretched
from Toy Story 3 while it's head also
kind of looks like buzzes nemesis /
father xored from Toy Story 2 now if you
watch a lot of Pixar films you know that
there's always say Pizza Planet truck
hidden somewhere and one in this movie's
a bit harder to find but if you look at
the carnie who operates the booth on his
leg is a Pizza Planet truck tattoo and
in this carnival exterior at some point
the movie was kind of hard for me to
find them but many have said that they
spotted Bob Parr aka mr. incredible
sitting at one of the tables now buzz
ends up stuck as a prize in the booth
and it's always fun to notice the photo
realism that the animators keep working
more and more into these movies if you
look under the carnies fingernails it's
just a bit of dirt also lining this
booth are some guitar toys that match
the design of the guitars from Koko
there's some star plush toys with the
same blue and pink color scheme of Sully
from monsters Inc there are some white
rocket ships that match the piece of
planet logo and the prop ship outside
that restaurant in another prize is a
green frog one of these shows up in the
post-credits scenes he looks like the
Frog who teased lots o on the grill of
the truck at the end of Toy Story 3
beside Buzz is a toy with a red star on
a yellow circle matching the famous
Pixar luxo ball design and here buzz me
it's ducky and bunny voiced by
keegan-michael key and Jordan Peele
ducky kicks buzz in the head saying
that's a nod to the tagline of the movie
alien and Buzz using his helmet like
this it's a callback to the move that he
used on woody in the first movie there's
actually an interesting animation detail
here though when Buzz gets kicked his
head stretches all the way over to the
side it passes through his shoulder
now this spacing is physically
impossible because there's no gap in the
dome rim for his
to fit in there's just hard plastic
there this is an example of clipping
it's famous from hilariously bad video
game graphics and actually happens a lot
in animation there's actually a shot
during let it go in frozen when elsa
flips her hair back and the braid passes
through her arm but this isn't
necessarily a mistake sometimes the
animators just do this to make the
motion smoother or in Buzz's case here a
lot funnier and in the nearby playground
bo-peep helps woody with her skunk car a
quick shot shows that this car is
powered by B and L brand batteries BN L
of course is the mega-corporation from
Wally that took over the earth and
destroyed it let's safely escorted
surviving people away a nice cruise ship
Bo's sheep bring her a grape soda cap
which is the badge that Elia gave Carl
when they were kids and up and the one
that Carl later passed on to Russel and
then three combat Carl's appeared with
Arctic combat Carl always left hanging
but he doesn't get his due thanks to do
kaboom in the post-credits scene combat
Carl is voiced by Carl Weathers and he
first showed up in the Toy Story Tara
short that I brought up but let's move
on to the antique store where much of
this movie takes place the filmmakers
have said that they animated 10,000
items in it and while not all of these
are Easter eggs if you pause any frame
you probably will find something
familiar challenge accepted first off
the stores name is second-chance
antiques a reflection of the movies
theme of redefining one's purpose with
toys like woody and Gabby getting a
second chance at life the stores address
is 1,200 a nod to Pixar Animation
Studios address of 1,200 park avenue in
Emeryville California the sign also says
that it was founded in 1986 which is the
same year that Pixar broke off from
Lucasfilm to become its own animation
studio inside the store our Easter eggs
to pretty much every Pixar film on a
high shelf as a miniature Model T Lizzy
from the Cars movies on another shelf is
a box of Casey jr. animal cracker
cookies just like the one that Pete III
used for his traveling circus in a bug's
life there's also a green diving mask
like the one worn by the dentist when he
caught Nemo and Finding Nemo
there's also Carl's cane from up on an
upper shelf and speaking of up there's a
painting of dogs playing poker a nod to
the famous Cassius Coolidge painting and
the cigar ad series by Brown & Bigelow
but here the dogs are dug and the other
dogs from up on the walls you can find
an unlit neon sign for Dinoco
gasps there's also a 70s design sign
showing a113
which is of course another common
animation Easter egg it references the
famous classroom at CalArts where many
of these Pixar animators studied another
sign reads ye olde poultry palace
another nod to the Toy Story small fry
fast food chain and elsewhere around the
shop are vintage ads for triple dent gum
the obnoxiously catchy jingle from
inside out in a vintage ad for Eggman
moving company the movers from the first
Toy Story there's also a chandelier from
which an MU flag hangs that's for
monsters University the college that
Mike and Sulley went to in the Monsters
Inc prequel now somewhere hidden away in
the story are yellow monsters ink screen
canisters as well as elastic girls
elasticized ears Incredibles too
there's also Bing bongs red wagon rocket
ship from inside out a bear carving
referencing brave and a dollhouse that's
a miniaturized version of Carl and
Ellie's house from up there's also a
stack of LP records and one of them is
remember me this song from Koko and
there's a stack of board games including
ones titled Knick Knack and lifted for
the Pixar shorts of these same names now
in this section woody and forkie meet
Gabby Gabby voiced by Christina
Hendricks Hendricks said that she
actually played with ventriloquist
dummies as a kid making this perfect
casting because Gabby's henchmen are
these creepy dummies led by Benson the
animators studied mannequins structure
how their arms just dangle and their
legs bent backwards and their mouths
drop open their feet drag it makes them
the perfect nightmare material in this
movie the creepiness of this
introduction is accentuated by the
old-timey music which you probably
recognize as midnight the stars in new
from the famous closing shot of Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining picks our
animators have actually snuck in shining
references to several toy story films
the carpet pattern of SIDS house is the
same pattern from the Overlook Hotel and
in Toy Story 3 the dump truck license
plate reads RM 237 or room 237 in a
shining plus Trixie's online boyfriend
is named vilasa star 237 there's
actually another 237th easter egg in
this movie when duckie and bunny pitched
their plush attack plan a montage
follows home the shop owner Margaret and
we see that her house number is 237 also
in Margaret's refrigerator in her house
a Chinese food takeout carton that same
carton has shown up in a Bug's Life Toy
Story 2 monster's Inc ratatouille and
inside out and Incredibles 2 in the shot
of ducky and bunny tackling Margaret
with a plush on the shelf behind her is
a stone dragon which appears to be Mushu
from Mulan and Margaret's key which
they're trying to retrieve resembles the
Keyblade
from the Kingdom Hearts games and here's
my favorite Easter egg in this movie
behind the cash register Margaret has
pinned up a photo of Jerry the old man
from Jerry's game in that chest short
implying that Jerry was an old flame of
hers now in this interior setting the
animators photo realism is again super
impressive various dust marks and
scratches on the walls and floor there
are cobwebs that stretch everywhere the
filmmakers actually said that Pixar
actually invented an animation
technology to recreate how a spider
spins its web x' the shop also contains
nods to pixar history there's a
cube-shaped thing with pixar written on
it
this was Pixar's early graphics computer
from the 80s
Pixar would use this as a logo later on
in its early shorts and near this
computer is Arlo the dinosaur from the
good dinosaur but there's also a hand
sculpture which is actually a scan of
the hand of Pixar animator and former
Pixar president idi Catmull who
co-created the first 3d computer
recreation of a hand in 1972 which later
led to the short film a computer
animated hand both leads Woody to this
hideout in it's inside a vintage game
called Tiki party with art inspired by
the Tiki heads from inside the fish tank
and Finding Nemo and inside are even
more Easter eggs they're graded by tinny
from the pixar short tin toy
there are also tiny vintage Star Wars
toys with the Alec Guinness obi-wan
Kenobi had Ponda Baba from a new hope
actually notice that obi-wan is striking
pandas arm and later that arm pops off a
nod to win obi-wan severed pontas arm in
the Mos Eisley cantina also in this
hideout is Franklin the Eagle from the
Toy Story small fries short he was part
of the discarded toys support group and
then they meet Duke kaboom voiced by
Keanu Reeves the filmmakers said that
Dukes introspective monologue was
inspired by Reeves himself who kept
asking questions about Duke and dug deep
into his soul they said that at one
point while they were talking to him
Keanu stood up on the table in the
middle of Pixar's atrium started
striking poses come
a victory which inspired dukes poses in
this movie also of course they featured
Duke Sain whoa
a nod to Keanu's line in Bill and Ted
and the matrix and when we see Dukes
backstory with the Canadian boy had he
disappointed we learned that his
backstory is actually similar to Buzz
Lightyear's a cool toy that was
traumatized by not being able to soar as
far as the commercial said he'd be able
to by the way the announcer on duke
booms commercial was flee from the Red
Hot Chili Peppers now during this rescue
mission when the toys looked down into
the shop there's a full luxo ball
visible on the floor and during the
scramble woody freezes in place while
holding the phone receiver posing in the
same exact pose as the Mickey Mouse
phone Duke and woody jumped the ramp to
the center cabinet and right as they hit
the ledge they passed this license plate
now this plate is from carb account II a
reference to carburetor County the
fictional county in cars where Radiator
Springs is located also the registered
city on the plate is torque ville
another fictional setting in the Cars
universe they rescue four key from Gabby
Gabby and Beau slides in uses her staff
to sweep the leg while doing so she
passes a commemorative plate with this
sword logo this is the crest of Merida's
family clan from brave woody allowed
Gabby to take his voice box but Gabby's
intended plan to use her voice to win
over the girl harmony fails because
harmony sucks and she tosses Gabby aside
but thanks to four key and bow what he
realizes that this can be his purpose
helping toys like Gabby who feel lost to
find their new forever kids because he
learned from his battle with lot so that
not all toys have to end up that way and
in doing so this Pixar film is able to
return back to the older Pixar rules a
story with no villain because not all
stories need a source of evil that needs
to be conquered sometimes the battle
could just be an inner one with a
character learning the key lesson
meanwhile buzzes gag in this movie is
taking literally the pre-recorded voices
inside him at one point he taps it over
and over and one of the voices says open
the pod bay doors which is of course a
nod to the famous line in Kubrick's 2001
a Space Odyssey open the pod bay doors
help in Dukes buzz parallel continues
with his big jump at the end which he
does with his eyes closed just like how
buzz closed his eyes while attempting to
fly in the first film
Duke passes over the hole
moon and out of the famous shot in ET
and woody says goodbye to his old
friends he passes on his sheriff's badge
to Jesse and like having his pull-string
removed this is the final visual
connecting him to Andy into Bonnie
he's severing his tether to the kids who
no longer need him and we learned that
woody Beau and the rest are headed to a
town called New Stanton which is a nod
to Andrew Stanton the longtime Pixar
animator and writer director who
directed films like Finding Nemo in
wall-e and the film's final exchange
buzz leaves on the RV waving to his
longtime buddy saying to infinity and
woody watches them go completing the
phrase with and beyond this movie
reestablishes this famous line from a
meaningless commercialized toy
catchphrase - the perfect description of
Woody's destiny infinity is by
definition undefined it just goes on and
on and on just like these toys do and
now with a new purpose that could get
redefined again and again as Woody's
future takes them on a new path it is
now Woody's turn to go to infinity and
beyond
now I broke down this movie's
post-credit scenes in another video go
check that out but my question for you
is which movie do you think had the
better ending Toy Story 3 or Toy Story 4
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA boss and subscribe to new rock
stars for in-depth breakdowns of all the
movies that you love and now that this
breakdown is over let's play things out
with some Randy Newman UK the freedom
you gave me
[Music]